hi my name is Nick and I know the first
two words of the Canadian national
anthem I'm excited to sing the Canadian
national anthem I know all about it
my grandma is from Thunder Bay Ontario
and she sings it all the time so I feel
like I know the very beginning really
really well and then I'm pretty sure I
know all the words because I learned the
song in junior high because I was that
kid but I've sung the Canadian national
anthem plenty of times I lived in Canada
for four years I'm American I'm pretty
sure I never learned
true patriot love in all thy sons
command nothing you should command
anyone to love you sons and daughters I
never really got why your hearts would
glow that seems like an ET related issue
I love that they delineate themselves as
the true north as like North America
sure but the northern part Canada
that's where it's celebrating this
sounds like Game of Thrones
it sounds like a Christmas Carol I knew
it was like something like far and wide
and about the I thought the first thing
about the plains but I couldn't even
understand them they mean that because
Canada only lives on the far and the
wide there's nothing in the center
talking about freedom now like their
America the bad you're really good at
the Winter Olympics french-speaking part
of your nation
play hockey I think you guys might
actually have it wrong
really the Canadian national anthem is
blame Canada like come on like South
Park rewrote it and that's what it is
now maple syrup I don't know I think I'm
some like a Christmas carol I'm in so
much trouble
I knew Oh Canada which is more than I
know for probably any other national
anthem it sounds like a regular old
national anthem lots of God and stuff in
there so that's good this country is
great we all love it hey guess what
Canada we're gonna protect you all the
time because we love you you're the true
north you're really really cold and most
people don't want to inhabit you but we
will protect you from those urchins that
do